welcome everybody i received an
incredible amount of reaction and
feedback to yesterday's segment where we
looked at some of the things that
attendees at a recent trump rally were
saying cultists and conspiracy theorists
visibly disoriented people clueless
individuals ignorant folks etc
and a ton of reaction from you about
what is fundamentally you know we
when hillary clinton talked about
deplorables
these are deplorables there's no
question about it these are some of the
worst of the worst participants to the
extent that they're even really
participating in the american political
landscape and many of you wrote to me
and said david how do we fix this how do
we fix what what possible solution could
there be to the fact that these
neo-reactionaries as i call them
um are increasingly prevalent and
present in american politics and as bad
as things are already and as bad as
things got under donald trump
we are i think many of you were reacting
to
the realization that we're only a few
house and senate votes away
from the absolute worst of the worst
people like marjorie taylor greene and
lauren bober and others gaining total
power of the united states political
system they have some power right now
but fortunately because you've got a
whole bunch of democrats and then also
some republicans with whom i disagree
but who aren't crazy
like the conspiracy theorists
they don't have total power people like
green and bober but we're close right i
mean if we saw a little bit of a shift
they would actually have real power in
the united states
and
look at the struggle we're in
to defeat this complete and total
irrationality it shouldn't be this
difficult these are folks you know in a
sane country
it wouldn't be this difficult to keep
people
like marjorie taylor greene madison
cawthor and lauren bobert even trump
himself in a sane country
trump coming out and saying people are
flushing toilets 10 times and mexicans
are rapists and criminals we would have
said wow that's crazy but this person
never has a chance
they're not going to win the primary
never mind become president but in this
country because of the electorate it is
that difficult in a normal universe
reality and simple logic
would be the overwhelming favorite to
win
it would be the default and it would be
the norm and yet here we are
we're teetering really on the brink of
becoming a country run by people who
believe our major problems are
satan worshiping politicians and
celebrities having to flush toilets 10
to 15 times
theories that aren't even being taught
to kids at school being public energy
number one
athletes who kneel
whether m ms are attractive enough to a
fox news host supposed socialism and
communism
a couple of dr seuss books that are
being taken out of circulation bill
gates adrenochrome
you know mexican refugees and immigrants
and their children
climate change mitigation as the enemy
not as something that we need to do but
that's the enemy
windmills causing cancer woke math
jewish space lasers i mean like think
about that's not a short list i could go
on there are even more imaginary
problems i could tell you about
and the dangerous part comes in when we
think about who these folks most remind
us of and now i'm talking about the cult
followers
dealing with cultists
doesn't always end well for them or for
others
and you know think about waco the waco
siege also known as the waco massacre
when law enforcement uh went to the
compound that belonged to the religious
sect the branch davidians think about
ruby reid ruby ridge the 11 day siege
in 1992
um when uh it was another one of these
cult elements we don't even need to talk
about the entire thing
jim jones and the people's temple and
the mass
murder-suicide
heaven's gate the
religious movement uh again and i i
believe there the term mass suicide is
more appropriate maybe it's
murder-suicide um donald trump got like
47 of the popular vote in 2020. if we
imagine that half of those voters are
cultists you're talking about 35 million
people
if you say well only a quarter of them
are real cultists it's still 17 and a
half million people if only an eighth of
them are cultists it's still close to 10
million people so the main question that
many of you are concerned with and you
keep asking me is how do we defeat the
insanity we all know that with the
republicans and these neo-reactionaries
it's all
ignorant unthinking projection and
hypocrisy and double standards but we
know that just pointing out hey that's a
double standard like you say you're
against regulation but now you're saying
regulate social media and regulate
businesses by telling them you can't
require vaccines it's a double standard
that doesn't work they don't care it's a
feature not a bug that they claim these
are our principles but they abandon them
as soon as it's inconvenient you can't
really use their own arguments against
them because they don't care
so is the solution to instead focus on
how these people
bring no solutions ever they just attack
imaginary problems maybe that should be
the focus tell us exactly how you would
do x and they don't and they can't and
they have no ideas maybe that's the
approach i don't know
but think about what a country run by
these people would look like it would
without a doubt be essentially a white
christian heterosexual
reactionary right-wing country period
we can't ignore
the effect that barack obama's
presidency as a half-black man had on
many of these these folks as upset as
they were
that a liberal
black man was in the white house
we saw that they
immediately had to start manufacturing
stories about obama's character flaws
because fundamentally it was never about
policy
oh he went to a church that we don't
like look at the things look at people
trump's associated with he wore a tan
suit he's an elitist who wants dijon
mustard
uh he wasn't born here birth certificate
etc and what donald trump did he didn't
create these people but the trump white
house gave these people
the language to express their
reactionary nature
with some plausible deniability that
they had been searching for for decades
for so long they couldn't say the things
they were really thinking because they
were so vile and disgusting and
xenophobic and racist and whatever and
trump provided them a language
that includes
america first
dealing with immigration we're going to
fix trade all of these different things
that gave them the language to say the
things they had been thinking a long
time without being totally branded as
what they actually are
just remember
um they don't want
to talk to
each other
and actually have the open dialogue on
ideas they claim they want to have
what they actually want is to impose
their ideas from above and silence
everything else while claiming that they
are for free speech that's what a lot of
the battle on social media is right now
their priority is own the libs
suffocate the ideas of the libs
and that's the the ultimate goal it's
the silence and at the end of the day
if they get their way
where do they imagine everybody who
isn't like them will go like in their
vision of america
do
the people they don't like stay with
some kind of second-tier status well
that's horrifying do they imagine
everybody else leaves a
a peaceful segregation as some white
nationalists talk about i don't know
you can't possibly come up with an
answer to that type of question when
you're not dealing with rational human
thinking individuals to begin with and
at the end of the day politics
requires some compromise and it requires
some rationality
but these neo-reactionaries believe that
they are acting some of them believe
they're acting literally in the name of
god with others it's a pseudo-deity
that's at the head of their cult it
could be trump or it could be marjorie
taylor green or whoever so they won't
compromise they can't compromise and i'm
as scared as you are about the path
forward if you have some idea about how
to productively deprogram these people
i still want to put together what might
be some kind of coherent strategy let me
know
many people going bonkers about the
reportedly accepted offer for elon musk
to buy twitter
there are people who on the right are
welcoming this with open arms saying
free speech will return to twitter and
oh it's going to be great and you have
people on the left saying this is a
dystopian nightmare let's talk through
what's going on and then i will give you
my take on it twitter has accepted elon
musk's buyout deal the report is that
twitter's board has accepted the uh
offer for elon musk to take the company
private twitter's a publicly traded
company right now the idea would be that
elon musk has secured financing at 54.20
per share to buy the company and to take
it private
there were rumors floating that many
said there's no way this is happening
and it appears to be now it still needs
to actually go through the due diligence
and regulation phase and it's possible
that this will fall apart but i'm more
concerned with what the reaction to this
should be
now one of the problems i'm having with
the reaction for many
is that it is very very black and white
either this is our elon musk is our
savior and he's going to save twitter
and he's going to unban everybody and
trump will be back and all these
different things and then the other side
of it is that this is the absolute worst
thing that could happen because elon
musk is just an absolutely terrible
person one of the problems that we're
facing in the united states
and around the world but in the united
states is that everything is based
around personalities and and cults of
personality and i think we should resist
that and we should resist it very
strongly as i've said before when it
comes to elected officials uh i don't
see politicians and elected officials as
being any different than you or i
they're just people they have some good
ideas they have some bad ideas they have
good instincts they have bad instincts
and we've talked about the dangerous
cult of personality around donald trump
but i was the first to tell you as a
bernie supporter in 16 and 20
i didn't like the cult of personality
that developed around bernie bernie can
do no wrong oh you don't like what he
said well you must have misunderstood
what he said or you're deliberately
misstating what he said he no he can do
no wrong cult of personality around
tulsi gabbard there was one around
andrew yang there's one around jordan
peterson i'm against all of it we need
to just see people
as uh more nuanced than that and so when
we talk about someone like
uh elon musk who's that's who's that
question here
does elon musk have a history
of um
suppressing unionization at his
companies yeah yeah and i'm against that
that's not good
has elon musk dramatically accelerated
the path forward on a number of
important technologies 100
the current
rush that every manufacturer of
automobiles has not only to put out
electric vehicles but to put out
electric vehicles whose range can match
that of tesla
is only happening because of what elon
musk did with tesla and
at tesla bad things have also happened
there's allegations of racism there's
allegations of union busting all of
these different things but
the tesla advancement of electric
vehicles with a greater than 300 mile
range as a just normal thing has led to
chevy
ford audi mercedes rivian all these
different companies saying hey we gotta
up our game we've got to compete here
that's a great thing
when you talk about the return to space
and spacex
musk reinvigorated what is now an
increased
interest in getting back to space which
i think is good
starlink satellite internet anywhere in
the world these are great things and
from a business standpoint
i've learned it's not a good bet to bet
against elon musk when he's determined
to do something and he also has some
terrible political instincts tweets
horrible things
and has all of these other things that
that aren't very progressive to me
uh the track record on free speech as we
we have a report from cnbc about uh
musk's record on free speech it's not a
great record he has sought control over
what journalist bloggers analysts and
others say about his businesses he's
reportedly cancelled people's
a blogger's tesla order when the blogger
blogged something elon musk didn't like
so what does this mean for twitter i
have absolutely no idea it could be bad
there's no doubt about it but i think
the problem i'm having is that all of
the discussion 99 of the discussion is
based around people's pre-existing
opinion about elon musk as a uniquely
great figure or as a uniquely terrible
figure and that seems extraordinarily
short-sighted my main concern with musk
buying twitter
is that of consolidation and monopoly
i don't really love the idea
of one person controlling so many major
companies elon musk's going to control
twitter
and tesla which is now i believe by
market cap the largest auto manufacturer
in the united states
uh and spacex which is i believe the
most important private space exploration
come it start the consolidation of power
is my uh primary concern will trump be
back on twitter as a result like is elon
musk planning to unban trump i have
absolutely no idea trump says he doesn't
plan to go back on that may change that
seems like a minor detail at this point
so let me know your thoughts about the
twitter takeover but try to make them
substantive rather than driven by just
your opinion of elon musk as an
individual which the right just is
they're praying at the altar of musk
and it seems unhinged and also i'm
seeing some on the left who are just
painting him as a uniquely evil
character which also doesn't strike me
as accurate let me know your thoughts
i'm on twitter at deepakman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
the david pakman show is an audience
supported program and i would love for
you to sign up at
joinpackman.com get yourself a
membership you'll get an extra show
every day called the bonus show alex
jones hates the bonus show oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves is bad he hates it that's a
sign it's probably pretty cool you can
sign up at joinpakman.com and you can
use the coupon code wow 22 to get a
discount we have some incredible text
messages that have been leaked you may
remember a guy named mark meadows mark
meadows was donald trump's
final chief of staff lasting up through
uh the end of trump's presidency cnn has
obtained
uh more than two thousand about twenty
three hundred in fact text messages uh
involving mark meadows and what they
expose is truly incredible what we have
learned and we're going to look at some
of these text messages momentarily
they were brainstorming
how to lie
about the trump riots how to cover their
you-know-whats about the trump riots
they were coordinating a response that
they knew wasn't actually based in fact
and we're going to look at a couple of
these text messages these are
fascinating sean hannity the fox news
propagandist texted mark meadows and
said is north carolina going to be okay
and mark meadows said to hannity stress
every vote matters get out and vote on
radio and hannity responds
yes sir
quite literally
fox propagandist taking his marching
orders from the chief of staff of the
president of the united states we
suspected it
but here we have the proof
sean hannity responded on it any
particular place we need to push and
meadows wrote back pennsylvania north
carolina arizona nevada
and hannity says got it everywhere
um there were some texts with uh matt
schlapp and mark meadows which aren't
super
interesting um
on november 6th just after the election
jason miller was putting out
um talking points so that others could
argue that something's fishy and trump
probably won
texting one other key data point in 2016
trump received 15.5 percent of the vote
in philly county today it is he's at
18.3 percent so he did better in that
county in 2016 philly county made up
11.3 percent of the total vote as it
currently stands philly county only
makes up 10.2 percent of the statewide
vote tally so
trump performed better in a smaller
share santorum was just making this
point on cnn cuts hard against the urban
vote stealing narrative okay so they're
coming up with these ideas to try to
support the claim false not based in
evidence that trump actually won
um
rick perry texted mark meadows we have
the data-driven program that can clearly
show where the fraud was committed this
is the silver bullet pam bondi
misspelled has seen and agrees
all day every day just sending these
things back and forth back and forth
back and forth
jenny thomas the wife of supreme court
justice clarence thomas was texting mark
meadows trying to understand the sydney
powell distancing
remember this was when the trump
campaign said oh sydney powell that
crazy lawyer she's on her own she's not
really with us and meadows wrote back
she doesn't have anything or at least
she won't share if she does to which
jenny thomas responds wow
wow
some other uh text messages that i want
to look at with you
donald trump jr texted mark meadows on
january 6th as the riots were taking
place and said he's got to condemn this
s asap the capital police tweet is not
enough
mark meadows writes back i'm pushing it
hard i agree
this his one you go to the mattresses on
they will try to f his entire legacy on
this if it gets worse
don jr
seemingly unable to talk sense into his
own father
was texting mark meadows saying the one
tweet isn't enough they're gonna screw
him
on this
mick mulvaney texted mark meadows saying
mark he needs to stop this now can i do
anything to help
republican congressman william timmons
tested texted the president needs to
stop this asap they all knew how bad
this was and they knew it was trumpists
and they knew it was bad for trump on
january 6th
renz priebus
texted mark meadows saying tell them to
go home
they all knew what it was and how bad it
looked they all knew it and yet publicly
they continued to spin a different line
and that night january 6 at night the
very fox hosts who were texting with
meadows and they all knew it was
trumpists they all knew trump wasn't
doing enough to stop it fact that he
instigated it they went on fox and they
said oh you know it could have been
antifa
could have been black lives matter who
knows what it was who it was
so recently democratic congressman jamie
raskin said
he now is convinced that this was a
coordinated effort to cause these riots
and then to run interference he says
they have the evidence they have the
testimony and it's going to come out
and now we have the texts whether this
is all of it or part of it we don't yet
know
but the story republicans wove we knew
it was not accurate that's not a shock i
mean we're now what is it 15 months in
we knew that they weren't telling the
truth
but now we know that it was a
coordinated and knowing effort to
deceive
not they just had the wrong
understanding of what happened it's
truly incredible
last friday i covered a hearing under
oath at which radical repugnant
congresswoman marjorie taylor greene
testified
and the point of the hearing was to
ascertain
whether she incited an insurrection on
january 6. the idea is if green incited
the insurrection
she can't run in 2022 because you're not
allowed to incite an insurrection and
then hold office so there was this
hearing she was under oath now she
repeated that she didn't remember
just about anything she was asked did
you ever suggest to trump that he uh put
in place martial law and she said i
don't remember
uh did you ever say that nancy pelosi
should be shot she said oh i don't
remember
on and on and we all knew that she was
lying we know she remembers but i don't
recall is a legal strategy because
you're not denying that you said it
which can be proven wrong you're just
saying you don't remember and the idea
is i don't remember i don't remember i
don't remember they can't prove i'm
lying this goes away now
we know that she committed heavy perjury
and we're going to look at some examples
many of you will email me and you'll say
david you're not in a position to say
whether it's perjury because you don't
know what was in her mind
perjury
is state of mind do you know that when
you say i don't remember you actually do
remember and i can see that we're not in
a courtroom here what we are saying is
unless she has serious dementia it's not
plausible
that she didn't remember anything that
was disadvantageous but then when her
lawyer starts asking her the details of
what happened on january 6 jesus well at
1 30 we were moved into a secure
location and then i received a text
telling us that there had been shots
fired and oh now you do remember so
we're in a court of public opinion here
on the david pakman show and it's
obvious that she committed very heavy
perjury let's look at some examples here
marjorie taylor green let's see if we
can get these up marjorie taylor green
on january 17th
texted mark meadows and said in our
private chat with only members several
are saying the only way to save our
republic is for trump to call for
martial law i by the way instead of
marshall
m-a-r-t-i-a-l she spells it marshall
like the name
m-a-r-s-h-a-l-l which is we're not even
gonna get into that that's funny too i
don't know on those things i just wanted
you to tell him they stole this election
we all know they will destroy our
country next please tell him to
declassify as much as possible so we can
go after biden and anyone else so she
said to mark meadows uh i want you to
tell them people martial law communicate
to him that martial law is something
that should be considered and then
she was asked during the hearing about
this and here's what she said
uh ms green did you advocate to
president trump to impose martial law as
a way to remain in power i don't recall
so you're not denying you did it you
just don't remember i don't remember
okay all right well maybe that one she
genuinely doesn't remember
well uh she was also asked
what were you thinking
when all of the invasion started
happening of the capital who did you
think was doing it and she said well we
thought it was antifa or black lives
matter and
when you
were notified
that people had entered the capitol
illegally did you also understand that
point that there had been violence at
the capitol
i only knew what i was told i'd heard
i'd heard a gunshot we all heard it
and
we were so confused we thought antifa
was breaking in or blm because of those
were the riots that had gone on and on
all throughout 2020 day in and day out
so she says in the moment they thought
that it was antifa or black lives matter
rioting at the capitol even though we
all knew it was the trump people who
were at the rally they just walked and
started rioting at the capitol but it
doesn't even seem that she believed that
because we now have another text
that she sent to mark meadows as this
was going on where she said mark i was
just told there's an active shooter on
the first floor of the capitol please
tell the president to calm people this
isn't the way to solve anything
nothing there about we think it's antifa
nothing about we think it's black lives
matter and more pointedly
if it was antifa or black lives matter
they're not going to listen to trump
saying calm down why would trump calm
down his enemies trump would only be
able to calm down the people on his side
so another example she obviously knew
obviously knew that the people there
were trumpists last example for today
although there's many more
during marjory taylor green's under oath
hearings she was asked about a capital
rioter named anthony aguero
and
in the testimony
she said he's a distant friend i've not
spent much time with him he's just a
distant friend although aguero referred
to marjorie taylor greene as a great
friend as a close friend well there is
now deleted video marjorie taylor green
has deleted this video
where she said
he is a great friend of hers take a look
at this because my friend anthony is my
dear dear friend
my dear dear friend anthony not a
distant friend no no my dear dear friend
i love him so much he's one of the
greatest guys i know one of the greatest
guys i know i love him so much so just
another example of the obvious perjury
when marjorie taylor green said i don't
remember i don't recall not really my
friend i don't really know now i'm right
there with you to be prosecuted for
perjury
is very difficult you have to prove she
knew she was lying you have to prove she
did remember so it's strategic memory
loss and by every legal analysis i've
seen it's an effective strategy but she
obviously lied we'll have these clips on
our instagram at david pakman show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show today we had a
horrible thing happen it happens every
once in a while we have a guest
scheduled beautiful guest and they no
call no show giving us no notice
whatsoever that they are not planning to
join the interview but the upside is
we'll hear from a few of you
via discord at davidpakman.com
discord let's go first
to rose from the united states rose it's
the united states is so general but
welcome
uh hello can you hear me yes i can
oh uh the artic quality is fine i know
you're quite a stickler for it it's it's
quite good thank you
okay um
yeah well um i i really feel
uncomfortable disclosing my location on
the internet
that being said uh my question is
there's a really big gap
between
scientists and the general public
and it feels like the gap keeps growing
and it gets more and more difficult to
convey to the general public
the
precise nature of science and the
difficulties associated with it it feels
like scientists are failing as a
political entity
to
talk to the general public how do you
feel about this i agree with you i mean
i think here's the thing
if you told me my i'm not a scientist
but i my instinct is if you told
scientists you are failing as a
political entity they would say we're
not a political entity and i but at the
same time i acknowledge what you're
saying which is
we i mean maybe it's science education
that's failing and critical thinking and
epistemology i don't i don't know but
you're absolutely right in your your
observation about the effects of it
what can we do because
i've i've spent so much time thinking
about this because
in light of global warming
it's way worse than what most reports
suggest
the most people don't know this but the
ipcc
is
meant to be a sort of a politically
favorable take on it it doesn't take
into account multiple feedback loops um
including the thawing of the permafrost
in the arctic uh it doesn't take take
into account ocean salinity which
changes demonstrated to dissolve in the
oceans etc so there like multiple
feedback loops going on
all of which
suggest that the reality of climate
change is going to be way worse than
what most people expect
the situation is more dire in other
words
yes yes
the ipcc reports are the best case
scenario the best possible hypothetical
scenario
and it's
and yet so many scientists i know
personally and i've talked to them about
this
um they are
they struggle to get people to
understand this and they're worried that
if they
actually talk about what's going to
happen
uh with real precision and actual facts
that they'll be dismissed as a
apocalyptic loons right so
and they're probably they're probably
correct to think that that's what would
happen
yeah i don't know how to bridge the gap
rose i mean this is this is an ongoing
conversation where
for it almost feels too late for so many
people and there's also the political
machine that that wants to stay on
fossil fuels that we're up against and
we need to start teaching critical
thinking and media literacy very early i
actually have a bunch of books
uh
waiting to be read on a pile that that
deal directly with this issue and so i'm
hoping in a few months maybe i'll have
some greater insights into it but
you're at least identifying the problem
correctly
could you share the book list um i'd i'd
love to read it i i will once i've read
the books because i always want to read
books before i recommend them but
absolutely
okay um it was great talking to you
today rose thank you so much
absolutely you too thank you thanks
david all right there is rose with a
very dystopian but necessary
commentary let's go to jimmy from
rochester jimmy you're on the air
hey david
hello
hey you can hear me i can hear you fine
cool
um so
lately i've been thinking a lot about
how uh
a person's ethical philosophy kind of
informs
their political stances on things
and especially how difficult it is
to argue
with someone who doesn't share your
ethical philosophy sure so
for example
uh like a libertarian would say
that you should never course
anyone basically
and so if you don't agree with that like
that's why they
don't want to be tax and that type of
thing well let me if i can jump in i
don't know that i necessarily agree with
the so with liberty i think
libertarians and non-libertarians alike
would often agree that coercion is bad
at a government level
the disagreement comes in what counts as
coercion for me that in your particular
example that seems to be the greater
dividing line
sure sure sure and and so
even
to take even a a
more obvious example
like the
the growth of like the trump business
the trumpism and in the country yes
um if
how can you
it seems as as if
it's not that we both want to get
the country to the same place
but we have different ideas on how to
get there
it's like we want to get it to
completely different places correct
so what do you do with that you know
what i mean like how do you
how can you
debate someone or argue or persuade
someone
when it's that different
on individual issues sometimes what
you're so
you are a hundred percent correct that
the the thirty thousand foot vision for
the united states of america is very
different for a trumpist than a social
democrat you're completely correct
but sometimes at the issue level the end
goal is the same so like for example
you find a lot to pick just to pick
something if you think about abortion
many people on the left agree
they would love to reduce the number of
abortions and people on the right say
that they want the number to be zero the
difference is the people on the left
would say well let's reduce abortions by
making contraception widely available
teaching comprehensive sex education
making sure women know that if they do
have a kid
they're going to be able to afford all
of the associated costs whereas the
right says let's let's ban it and make
people ashamed for even thinking of it
so
that's an example where even though the
vision is different if we can find some
similarity in the end goal then we can
engage as to how we most effectively get
there so some so i think maybe what i'm
saying is
while you're correct that the vision is
very different in different political
factions there might be some overlap in
the end goals with enough people on the
right that we could have some productive
conversations
that would be nice
it's it's a little bit pie in the sky
but at least it's it's an optimistic
perspective i guess
sure i mean yeah it's it
you have to start somewhere i suppose
yeah exactly
well i appreciate it all right thanks so
much for the call great to hear from you
uh why don't we go next to
um let's go to jamie from canada jamie
you're on the air
hey david how you doing i'm doing well
good i called in a couple times before
and most of my questions were
hypotheticals and i i don't know if if
it's harder to answer a hypothetical
question then a a question with the
factual basis in it um well that's uh
that question is in and of itself
hypothetical let me hear the two options
and then i'll tell you which question's
more difficult okay
um i was just wondering if
this is a hypothetical again this is a
hypothetical scenario i was just
wondering so say like democrats get
hypothetically sorry that's the word of
the day um
say they get hypothetically they get 52
dems and then um
then they decided to do the rules change
to like pass the what they what what
chuck tried to do back in january but
failed say hypothetically that like
mansion and cinemas are like well we're
switching parties so that it goes back
to 50 50. yes
do you see something like that happening
no
okay yeah no i don't think so okay
okay and another thing that i was just
wondering was
how do i talk to my mom about abortion
um
because well what are you trying to do
she's catholic and so she doesn't agree
with it okay well let me ask you this is
it is it merely an academic discussion
or is there some practical nature to the
discussion
um
no i it's it's a it's a it's act mostly
academic mostly emotional like she says
she doesn't agree with it whatsoever she
says she she she doesn't agree with it
on the on the principle of it whatsoever
well i'm curious jamie i mean you're in
canada and
abortion is relatively it's legal and
relatively accessible in canada is that
correct
yes so i guess my question is what do
you want to achieve what's the point of
fighting this fight with your mom is it
you just want to convince her for for
some reason well no i i don't want to
fight with her anymore um
she thinks it's something that it
shouldn't be and i said well i'm trying
to say to her i suppose my arguments in
the past have been very emotional
forward and she doesn't take too kindly
to that and i suppose i just wanted this
more
um factual way
of of of of you know having this
conversation with her well listen to
give to give you specific ideas we would
need to go into her people are opposed
to abortion for different reasons so you
need to kind of meet them where they are
and we don't have the scope to do that
here but one thing i would just think
about is is this really a fight you even
want to have with your mom you know
no no yeah so maybe you just don't
convince her you just just let her think
what she thinks i don't know yes and
she's
and um
she and you know it's funny um i don't
know i don't know if this is uh it's
funny even though i have uh argument
with her on abortion um she votes um
she votes green party um
yeah
and it's interesting i know and she said
she said probably this is the last year
i'm gonna vote that way um all right
well jamie keep us posted
thank you so much there's jamie from
canada he's got his hands full up there
that's that's clear let's go to aaron
from los angeles aaron welcome to the
show
hi david uh i just wanted to ask a quick
question regarding um i guess i don't
know if intellectual copyright is the
term um but there's been like i've been
reading a lot of articles regarding i
guess like bill gates and just to be
clear i am not an anti-vaxxer okay i
mean like i'm triple backs boosted and
everything so before i go into this i
just want to say that
i understand that bill gates is a source
of a controversy when it becomes um i
guess like intellectual property and
copyright like he has been involved in a
scandal regarding of vaccines not being
distributed to the global south as
quickly as they should be and a lot of
people are identifying this as a major
reason the coven 19 pandemic isn't
slowing down i was wondering what could
our congress do
to perhaps reform our intellectual
copyright laws to prevent i guess big
pharmaceutical companies from um
preventing you know necessary access to
the vaccines
well with it with vaccines specifically
the desire has been
for
the
vaccines to to essentially
not be protected by copyright or
intellectual prop patent protections and
just to be basically allowed to be open
sourced and produced anywhere and there
was a brief period where modernist said
we still have our patent but we're not
necessarily going to enforce it and you
know i i don't know ultimately what
happened with that there's a number of
different issues going on with vaccine
distribution but i i just i'm not
exactly sure
with vaccines specifically it's one set
of problems
bigger picture there's all sorts of
other intellectual property issues that
that exist and would be dealt with in
different ways so i i'm just i'm just
not sure how to address the question
okay uh yeah it's just i know that bill
gates has been tied up with intellectual
property rights even since like his
foundation of microsoft in the 1990s i
mean as a matter of fact before he was
getting into philanthropy a lot of the
controversies that he had regarding
microsoft's monopoly on the software
industry were really one of the things
that he was best known for yeah that was
the big issue about the bundling of
internet explorer with windows in which
he gave you know hours and hours of
pretty pretty uh
notable
depositions and uh yeah you're
absolutely right but i to be perfectly
frank i don't know that bill gates is
the biggest player right now and what's
going on with vaccines
okay i understand yeah yeah i i know
that it's just like in regards to
philanthropy i i understand that he he
does have a lot of influence with it i i
just think that like maybe the extent
could be overstated as a result of like
you know the various conspiracy theories
that are around him right now but uh i
guess that is just something i want to
look into i it's just i i honestly just
think that
if we don't slow down the effects of the
kova 19 pandemic you know in the global
south we're going to continue to see
these variants and i don't really i
don't know if it's going to lead to
another shutdown but i do think it's
definitely going to lead to a spread of
the infection yep and we're seeing cases
go up now and hopefully it won't become
a major spike but uh a point well said
and and well taken i appreciate the call
very much glad we could speak to a few
people today thanks to our guests
bailing on us we'll still take the
broader calls for our friday show we'll
take a quick break and be back right
after this
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick talk
so i'm really depressed about uh what's
going on in pennsylvania um as many of
you know we've been following the
pennsylvania senate race as i'll show
you in a moment the control of the u.s
senate after november after the midterm
elections could depend on who wins in
pennsylvania because of a number of
different dynamics and realities about
who's up for re-election and where are
their open seats and this type of thing
so we're very interested in who's going
to be the next senator from pennsylvania
on the democratic side i have been
leaning very heavily not that i vote in
pennsylvania but as an opinion i've been
leaning heavily towards john fetterman
the lieutenant governor
and on the republican side the story has
been that television dr mehmet oz
is running as a republican
and uh he has some celebrity donald
trump has endorsed him etc well last
night there was a democratic primary
debate and a republican primary debate
and i found both debates extraordinarily
depressing we're going to look at some
clips of the republican part i wasn't
able to find clips of the democratic
side but i watched it yesterday and
it was just really depressing so
fetterman whose policies i like
seemed
disoriented confused
he was slow to respond he didn't make
any sense it it was a terrible
performance where when i watched the
republican debate my thought was any of
the five candidates running on the
republican side would do well against
fetterman so while i like fetterman on
policy
his debate performance was terrible
um in terms of the other candidates on
the democratic side there was a woman
khalil i believe her last name was
and then a younger guy named malcolm
kenyatta and then conor lamb kenyatta
had some good answers but at one point
simply said no when asked whether he
wants to answer a question he said no
and it was bizarre
um and then conor lamb clearly the most
polished in terms of media preparation
but a very uninspiring kind of
center-left establishment democrat
it wasn't like wow one of these people
would crush a debate against these
republicans so that was on the
democratic side
it wasn't thrilling to say the least on
the republican side it was straight up
sinister disinformation i mean just
absolutely crazy and we're going to look
at a couple of clips first of all the
debate opened
with an argument over who's really from
pennsylvania based on how long they've
been in pennsylvania here's a little bit
of that 70 percent of republican voters
said the amount of time a candidate has
lived in pennsylvania is important we
begin with mr mccormick you've been
campaigning on your pennsylvania roots
but you have not actually lived in
pennsylvania for the last 15 years so
explain
why it seems that you returned to the
commonwealth just in time to run for the
u.s senate mr mccormick you have 60
seconds thank you mr oz uh except for
your time attending medical school and
graduate school you have not actually
lived in the commonwealth in
pennsylvania so how do you respond to
concerns that you do not know what is
best for pennsylvanians you have 60
seconds sir so so the first question
everybody just talked about how long
they had been in pennsylvania okay i
mean yes the voters claim they care
about it but it's already not actually
substantive
then there was the trump sucking up
portion of the entire thing where trump
endorsed dr oz and so dr oz in basically
every answer would mention that but
every candidate tried to suck up to
trump that was the next section he went
groveling to president trump president
trump saw right through him did not
endorse him and then he endorsed me
everything president trump put in place
worked the reason memo keeps talking
about president trump's endorsement is
because he can't run on his own
positions president trump won
pennsylvania and president trump
endorsed me president trump was very
clear i'm america first i'm the only
person in this race that was appointed
by president trump you say that you are
america first you did so much for
president trump and yet he rejected it
thank you mrs barnett once again trying
to tell pennsylvanians something that
president trump does not believe is true
president trump doesn't always get the
best advice i am the only conservative
voice no you're not dishonest dave is at
it again what president trump did he put
his finger on the fact that president
trump did was respect people who had
been othered forgotten cancelled
president trump coined the word maggot i
have discussed with president trump and
just like president trump that
experience is going to make me a better
senator so much so that president trump
on his teletown hall we need to enforce
the policies that worked under the trump
administration what president trump saw
right through him he therefore did not
endorse mr mccormick he endorsed me
president trump's policies trump was
able to put together operational warp
speed we saw under the trump economy all
right so you guys get the picture so
then it was an art first it was an
argument over who's lived in
pennsylvania the longest and long enough
then it was an argument over which of us
is the most liked by trump and most like
trump the funniest moment from the
entire thing was when dave mccormick who
seems to be kind of like the second you
know right up there with with mehmet oz
um and uh uh barnett they seem to be the
three front runners he said there's no
miracle cure which i love because you
know of dr oz's history as a guy
promoting all sorts of quack cures this
was that this was probably the funniest
moment and now he's flip-flopping and
the problem doctor is there's no miracle
cure for flip-flopping and
pennsylvanians are seeing right through
your phoniness and that's what you're
dealing with and that's why you're not
taking off in the polls so
that's actually great i mean dr oz
promoting you know drinkable silver and
various quack gears of different kinds
so that is actually pretty clever but
these are all absolutely terrible people
and unfortunately i hate to say this but
if i'm honest
the energy of any of these five
candidates likely would come off better
in a debate against the four democratic
candidates i saw yesterday i hate to say
it here's one last clip where uh
candidate sans attacks candidate barnett
for how how big her margin of loss was
in her previous election
and then they argue over who most
believes in the 2020 big lie in
washington you can count on me
they did not steal that election by 20
points she lost her last election to a
weak weak democrat john fetterman is not
a weak democrat he's strong i will beat
john fetterman in the fall thank you uh
i am going to give you 30 seconds to
respond thank you so much for that
because are you saying that there was
absolutely that that that the 2020
election was above par that there was no
fraud that there was no uh issues with
that
points are you telling me that it was
perfect and and if and because
apparently that's what she's saying so
for all of us in the republican party
now we have a candidate on stage carla
sand who is saying that there was
absolutely nothing to see in that 2020
election but beyond that uh you know you
say that you are america first you did
so much for president trump and yet he
rejected it thank you miss barnett and i
did not give you that information
i'm gonna give you 15 seconds quickly to
respond to that
president trump doesn't always get the
best advice
there were actually times where each
candidate was given 10 seconds sometimes
to respond i mean it's the format
doesn't work the candidates are lunatics
the topics are absurd so it's all
very very depressing now why does
pennsylvania matter so much well when
you look at 270 to win.com they have a
number of different uh maps that you can
look at if you look at the 2022
consensus map pennsylvania is one of
only five senate toss-up states if you
look at sabato's crystal ball
pennsylvania is one of only four toss-up
states if you look at the cook political
map pennsylvania is one of five toss-up
states and in the politico map it's also
one of five toss-up states if you run a
number of different scenarios and
consider them
in a lot of them pennsylvania decides
whether democrats control the senate or
whether republicans control the senate
and unfortunately i didn't find any of
it particularly exciting let me know
your thoughts if you watch the debates
i have a story for you today
that is a story about many things we've
been talking about and fundamentally the
story is about conspiracy theorists
moving to
central and south america mexico and
central america
and um starting kind of conspiracy off
the grid communes and it's really wild
but
it points to a number of different
issues we've talked about one is these
people rarely believe only one
conspiracy and that's what can make them
so so dangerous number two
there's almost always anti-semitism
there if you find any real conspiracy
believer there will almost always be
some openly or implicitly anti-semitic
belief and of course they're completely
unhinged so let's look at this clip this
is from vice news vice news went down to
check out these enclaves and uh
it speaks for itself
the brothers bring potential buyers to
tour the community of about 214 lots
right each lot starts at 20 000
plus the cost of building a house
about 20 of them have sold
people have asked me gabo so
i like ac can i have ac i said yes
you can have all the comforts you want
you can have internet you can have cable
tv
you're gonna have a nice kitchen so it's
like living in the city but in the
jungle right okay so we're gonna walk to
the phase two okay so where the lots are
available
okay
all of the conveniences of modern
society without any of its laws sounds
like a utopia
but when all conspiracies are given
equal credence some dark ideas can
appear this is wild what brings you here
today joanne we have a
big bunch of demons that are um trying
to control our lives uh so let's see
what's going on because we might have to
head to the hills so now here with
demons she might mean literal or
metaphorical demons we don't yet know
but just wait
i am worried about the graphene oxide in
the injections and i'm worried about the
um the vaccines covered vaccines well
they're not vaccines so i will not call
them that their injections their
injections of graphene oxide when you
add graphene oxide into the body and
you're hooking that to the cloud
this is craziness it's just hard for me
because so much of what you're saying
like i've never heard of before and it
goes against like a lot of the things
that i've been told are true you have
been i would even say it more strongly
because when you say you haven't heard
of something it's easy to say well you
got to inform yourself
um but really it's i there's been no
evidence presented
to suggest any of this is true
for so much and then you can kind of get
into something else which i accidentally
stumble upon which was
were there gas chambers in nazi germany
and there is six million people die in
nazi germany yes well
that's a great answer but it's probably
the wrong answer but joanne people
watching have lost relatives in the
holocaust they know people died so what
you are saying feels like an attack on
them personally no you're putting words
in my mouth and words in their mouth
what does this have to do with
off-grid living life so maybe people
can't see the lie in what's going on
with covet 19 but there are many books
and many many experts
took apart the gas chamber story 101
different ways
what do the rest of you guys think of
this there's always going to be
difference of opinions between people
this is normal human trait so we should
not um judge people based on what they
say or they don't say joanne is welcome
here and everybody's well absolutely
all of these alternative communities are
brought together by one thing
they're against the covet 19 vaccines
and mandates yeah so it's pr it's very
very scary stuff and this is why i tend
to agree increasingly with the
conspiracy and cult experts we talk to
who say yeah you know maybe they believe
flat earth stuff or they just don't want
the vaccine personally because they
think there's graphene oxide in it and
it'll link you up to the cloud or
whatever but there's often really ugly
stuff underlying it exactly as you saw
there and unfortunately that is not
going to be someone you can talk sense
into
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p here's a question about
tipping at restaurants
hi david um
i have been watching your show for
almost 10 years i turned 27 the other
day and i have been watching since i was
uh 18. wow um
i just wanted to ask you um what are
your thoughts on a sipping culture and
if you believe
uh in tipping or if you think that
restaurants should uh pay living wages
okay
i uh i am against tipping i don't want
uh i i hate first of all i hate the
ambiguity of how there are certain
situations where of course you know you
have to tip like restaurants but then
there are others where it's less clear
and it creates bad situations etc um i
my preference would be
restaurants list prices inclusive of
the full salary of the people that are
working there and you don't have to
worry about tipping this is increasingly
happening lots of places in new york
city are starting to do that
the tipping culture is not only
confusing to people traveling between
countries where the policy or
expectations are different it's also a
way for restaurant owners to get out of
actually paying employees properly i'm
against tipping but i tip 20 for good
service myself because i know that it's
not the fault of the
restaurant employees that that's the
system but i would like to get rid of it
and have a system that is much cleaner
don't tip prices already account for
properly paying our staff
that's all you've got to do that would
be my preference we have a great bonus
show for you today sign up at
joinpacman.com to get instant access we
will see you on the bonus show today or
back on tomorrow's show